الان عوده الى موضوع استشهاد الزميلين
الصحفيين حمزه وائل الدحدوح ومصطفى ثريا
ونتابع الان صورا مؤثره لوالده الشهيد
مصطفى وهي تحمله
وتنعي حامله شهيده في يدها ام تحمل شهيدها
في يدها الصحفي مصطفى سعيد طريه ودته الى
الجنان ذهبت به الى جنان النعيم اللهم
تقبله من الشهداء اللهم اني رضيت يا رب
ورضيت قسمت لي يا الله رضيت بان ابني يكون
من الشهداء الصح مصطفى سعيد ريه اللهم
تقبله من الشهداء اللهم تقبلهم من الشهداء
اللهم اجعله في عليين مع البر الصديقين
الصديقين او الانبياء يا رب العالمين
اللهم ارضى عنه اللهم اني رضيت عنه فارضى
عنه يا الله يا اللهم اني رضيت عنه اللهم
اني رضيت عنه فرضى عنه يا الله فرضى عنه
يا الله الله تقبله من
يعني
طارق حد
ينزل محمد